un invité remarqué accueilli en grande
pompe par le recteur de l'Université
d'Ottawa l'ambassadeur chinois au Canada
venu prononcer un discours sur le campus
depuis son passage lundi la controverse
prendre l'ampleur au Canada la liberté
de la presse pas
et que l'accès au discours de
l'ambassadeur chinois a été limité le
cameraman de Radio-Canada avait d'abord
été admis dans la salle pour
l'enregistrer mais en coulisses
l'entourage du diplomate chinois c'est
opposé à la présence des caméras
résultat l’université d'Ottawa a montré
la porte à notre caméraman
ne laissant pour seule option au
journaliste présent que d'enregistrer
avec leur téléphone intelligents c'est
un locution importantes
ou les mystère chinois dénonçait la
nouvelle stratégie adopacifique du
Canada
pendant le discours les stores ont même
été abaissés cachant les manifestants
Ouigours à l'extérieur c'est entrave au
travail des journalistes fait réagir on
est dans une pente glissante
excessivement glissante et ça ouvre la
porte à n'importe qui de demander
l'expulsion des journalistes on est vite
un ambassadeur d'un pays totalitaire on
lui fait comprendre dès le début que
c'est possible qu'il y a des
journalistes et des caméras dans la
salle qui partie des règles du jeu ce
professeur de journaliste est déçu de la
réaction de sa propre Université
d'Ottawa qui a réussi à qui a succombé
ou que plié sous la menace ou sous la
pression d'une vue ou d'une conception
totale et autoritaire de la liberté
d'expression ce n'est pas la première
controverse touchant la liberté
d'expression à l'Université d'Ottawa une
professeur à temps partiel avait été
suspendu en 2020 pour avoir prononcé le
mot en N la classe politique dénon son
bloc ce nouvel épisode pour moi ils ont
fait une erreur à bannir des caméras les
médiateurs
se soit prêté à ça me semble indigne
d'une institution qui est sensible de
jouer un rôle fort auprès d'une jeunesse
liberté des médias des journalistes
c'est une une trois fondamentale des
conservateurs s'inquiètent de
l'ascendant de la Chine sur les
institutions d'enseignement ça demande
clairement ce qui se passe au Canada
quand on parle d'ingérence interférences
que l'ambassadeur de Chine demande à
l'université de fermer les aux médias
par écrit l'Université d'Ottawa souligne
que sa conférence risquait d'être
annulée si les caméras avaient été
admises et rappelle que les journalistes
qui ont eu accès elle s'engagent à faire
les choses autrement la prochaine fois
sans mentionner la liberté de la presse
ici Louis Blouin Radio-Canada